[Music]
we saw at the Royal Wedding that was one
of those anything as possible moments
and a love moment as well
so do you have any advice going forward
for Megan and Harry nothing no but let
me just tell you about that Royal
Wedding it was transformative it was
more than a wedding I thought I thought
it it was a cultural moment and there
you could not be there or watching on
television coz then I came home and
watched the whole thing all over again
but you could not be there and not feel
that that there was a shift that just
happened in the middle of it so I think
it was it's bigger than it's bigger than
them and I think it bodes well for hope
for all of us yeah there was two things
I want to ask you real quick because
there were two things out there say
number one you'd have the first
interview with Harry and Megan is that
true I sure would like it to be true but
no I wasn't there trying to get an
interview I was just there no that
wasn't the story was you we're gonna get
it not that you were there getting it
that you were gonna get that is true I
do not know it but who doesn't want to
talk to her and Megan's mom that was the
story that you're gonna interview her no
I loved the story was that Megan's mom
had come to my house and she was led she
left laden with gifts
you know what the gifts were first of
all she's great at yoga so I said bring
your yoga mat and your sneaks in case we
want to just do yoga on the lawn so that
was one of the bags was yoga and the
other was for lunch we had a dessert
with kumquats and she said I love
kumquats and I said I have a kumquat
tree you want some kumquats so is a
basket of kumquats people if I haven't
people said I am lady I'm giving her
gifts I'm trying to bribe her for an
interview
they were kumquats if complex can get
you an interview I'm all for it
you
[Music]